es geht darum es geht um meine ansichten
im song anhörung und nicht um seine um
ihre das so wie ich denke aber trotzdem
noch mal zum gericht warum lässt du es
wirkt also jeder der dieses ding gesehen
hat denkt du hälst nichts von deutschen
gerichten
das ist kommt einfach super deutlich
rüber weil ich sage nur gott kann mich
richten die gläubigen schlusskurs
gläubig stopp am schluss kommen
bewaffnet leute rein oder aber das ist
doch guck mal reden wir jetzt vom sommer
reden vom video wir reden vom gesamt
kunst dass das ist das sind zwei
komplett verschiedene paar schuhe
das sind zwar kommen da die hängen ja
schon zusammen wenn ich das eine wenn
ich jetzt sehe ich kenne wie muss ich
kenne videos wo die wo das szenario vom
video nichts mit dem song zu tun hat gar
nichts weil dies ist aber nicht der fall
das szenario des songs schon ein wenig
des videos schon ein wenig mit dem song
so gut es geht also guck mal ist mir
schon klar dass das das ist jetzt nicht
also ich werde jetzt nicht morgen
wirklich vor gericht hin und dann
wirklich allen ernstes glauben dass ich
von 34 kollegen befreit werden können
dass das würde sich auch nicht gehören
darum geht es nicht aber es ist einfach
einen action-streifen was das visuelle
angeht also der song ich stehe hinter
jeder zeile vom song aber das video seid
einfach eine idee von der
produktionsfirma gewesen ok lassen was
so darstellen so das wird cool
das wird vielleicht sogar ein bisschen
brisant verschießt wie ich meine ich
weiß ja auch wie ich mit diesen ganzen
brisanten themen und provokationen
umzugehen habe und das ist einfach ein
action streifen ich habe schon mal
irgend einem anderen interview habe ich
das schon mal erwähnt aber wenn bruce
willis oder wenn bernd eichinger so ein
film dreht oder irgendjemand den action
streifen dreht dann ist es auch dann
redet keiner drüber aber bei mir ist ein
skandal
warum denn so empfindet es nicht ganz
klar nein warum was hat denn dieses was
hat denn dieser action streifen mit der
politik zu tun und wenn es so wäre
arnold schwarzeneggers der gewonnene
nächste große action held aus amerika
den es jemals gab neben anderen gut ich
will mal von einer anderen seite
aufgreifen canucks in paris das ist ein
klarer action streifen das ist das ist
überhöht das ist traumatisiert aber du
sagst ja selber dein song anhörung da
geht es dir um über dich persönlich geht
es ihr darum über nicht persönlich was
zu erzählen und das wird dann mit etwas
bebildert wo du sagst es ist ein action
streifen das ist kunst ja aber kannst du
nicht nachvollziehen dass die leute dann
ausflippen und sagen der kommt da so
wahrhaftig vor der kamera über tat
verbindet irgendwie es mit sowas ist das
nicht auch wahrhaftig ich kann es
nachvollziehen
also ich kann die ganze aufregung um
dieses wiederum nachvollziehen aber auch
spekuliert
überhaupt nicht also wir haben uns schon
gedacht okay das könnte leicht brisant
ankommen die idee stand auch
gar nicht am anfang so ich hätte auch
ganz anders machen können hätte ich
hätte auch nicht anrufen können und
sagen können
christoph hast du nicht mit mir video zu
drehen wir machen das im rahmen eines
interviews du bist der journalist und du
fragst mich land sie sich bitte zu der
frauenfeindlichkeit
es hätte richter sein müssen es hätte
auch ein klassenzimmer sein können oder
was weiß ich
aber wir haben uns einfach gedacht das
passt am besten es ist brisant warum
nicht machen wir das das auge isst mit
wir wollen cooles video drehen schwert
befreit die aufregung aber dass das so
groß wird in den medien
damit hätte keiner gerechnet aber es ist
mir wirklich scheißegal was mir
scheißegal
mir ist egal wer was darüber denkt ich
mache sowieso mein ding schon habe ich
schon immer gemacht ich hab mir von
niemandem was sagen lassen
macht also nicht oder macht macht das
auf diese art nicht ich stehe zu 100
prozent hinter dem song und der song ist
einfach ein meinungsmacher wie gesagt
und das video ist ein action streifen 40